wo ist dein weg
ja das sieht gut aus
diesmal schaffen wir das so schwer ist
kochen doch nicht zwiebeln schneiden das
mache ich du schneidest den feta käse in
kleine stücke alles ja wir brauchen 250
gramm danach schneidest du die tomaten
und den schinken klein und zum schluss
legst du alles auf den pizzateig schau
mal hier im kochbuch steht schneiden sie
zuerst den käse klein schneiden sie dann
die tomaten und den schinken in würfel
legen sie alles auf die pizza und
schieben sie die pizza für 20 minuten
bei 180 grad in den ofen
ok meine schwester kann sehr gut kochen
und backen ich leider nicht ich auch
nicht aber pizzabacken es läuft ja
guten appetit